chief CeCe retiree kills suffered a
collarbone injury on Sunday week one
against the Jacksonville Jaguars
technically a sternoclavicular joint
injury where the collarbone attaches to
the sternum
according to being wrapped before the
NFL Hill is expected to miss four to six
weeks will not be placed on injured
reserve able to come back whenever
whenever he's healthy and ready to go
but Chris this is an impact to the
Kansas City offense that is firing on
all cylinders and arguably doesn't need
him I mean look we're gonna find out how
critical Tyreke Hill is to this offense
now they've signed him to a three-year
extension he's under contract for four
more years so he's going to be part of
the team but we hit believed he was a
critical component over the next few
weeks we'll find out how much of it is
the quarterback and other receivers who
are able to do the same things that the
Chiefs do when Hills on the field how
much will they miss well they're gonna
miss them I mean it's it's just the
effect he has for the rest of the
offense that's so special but is it like
oh we're gonna miss them and now we're
gonna like not score 14 we're gonna
score 14 less extra points on a weekly
basis no absolutely not
I mean first off Andy Reed is a
phenomenal game planner he's a mad
scientist as far as drawing up crazy
schemes and new ways to do things
it was amazing some of the plays I saw
on film when I watched the Jacksonville
game and - the good thing is Mike and I
know you talked about this a little
yesterday the fact that they drafted
McCole Hardman in the second round gives
them that tyree kill flexibility is he
Tyriq ill no but he can play a similar
role - where he can scare a defense deep
the speed sweeps and things like that
you can give him the ball and he can
turn the corner and take it to the house
70 yards down the field so yes they're
gonna miss him but I think would they
have enough talent and Kelsey and
Watkins them in a homes that it's not
gonna be greatly missed this is still be
one of the best to high functioning
offenses in football yeah I agree with
you and Tyriq ill a very dangerous
presence on the field because of the
attention he commands I don't want to
understate that but between the two
Patrick mahomes the far more critical
presence on that Kansas City Chiefs
offense and look it's one thing to say
we can withstand
an injury to tyree kill but yeah the
next injury is the one that you have to
worry about and then the next one I mean
if Sammy Watkins gets injured then they
really do have a you're right you're
right that's where you know team's got
to be careful about positions that are
very important to their football team
that's why we see the Patriots you know
accumulate all these DBS and outside
linebackers slash linebacker defensive
end guys because they're not gonna let
one injury just oh gosh now we have to
change the schematics of our football
team and yeah that's what you get scared
of but the good thing for the Chiefs as
far as pertaining to Tyree killo and all
that you know you look at their next few
weeks of football right the Oakland
Raiders this week I mean they should be
able to get away with it now now the
week after that the Baltimore Ravens
game that's gonna be a game they wish
they had Tyree killed for because that
Ravens secondary is the real deal but
even after that it's favorable the few
weeks after that when you go Lions Colts
Texans I don't think any of those
defenses are gonna make like Patrick
mahomes and Andy Reid stay up late at
night where they're gonna go oh my gosh
this is such a great thing how are we
gonna move the ball on these football
teams so I mean they do have a little
bit of a grace period here other than
the Ravens game week three that I don't
think the task will be too tough with
the talent they already have yeah you
get him back for week seven at Denver
week eight Sunday Night Football on NBC
against the Green Bay Packers and maybe
they'll need him for that you you
weather that storm the good news is he
will be back he won't be placed on
injured reserve and the Chiefs will have
him they're just gonna have to get
through a few games without him and and
that's part of life in the NFL and
that's why for all the predictions that
we make going into the season they're
all premise taun players staying healthy
we know that there will be injuries that
will change a team's fortunes
dramatically we just don't know who we
don't know when we don't know how long
they're going to be out look at the
Jaguars Chris you and I both had them at
the top team in the AFC South now who
knows what's gonna happen would Nick
falls on injured reserve after having
his collarbone broken surgery on Monday
Gardner Minshew the second now the
quarterback he could be Kurt Warner Case
Keenum in 2017 dak Prescott in 2016
we're just gonna have to find out one
week at a time and that's
part of what makes it all fun to watch
how the dominoes fall because we think
we know how they'll fall but we know
that there's going to be those
disruptions and they're gonna fall in a
different way and we just take it a week
at a time and see how it goes yeah yeah
I mean it's a crazy League and one or
two of these injuries to big football
players on your team and you're in deep
trouble I will say I was really
encouraged Mike by watching Gardner
Minshew on film okay it really was it
gave me it gave me hope that the
Jacksonville Jaguars might be able to
survive this I'm obviously he's not as
good as Nick Foles at this point but he
was not fazed by the situation he's got
pretty good physical ability there's
some guys around him that Got Talent and
again that defense is still legit I'm
not gonna let Week one and like the
greatest offense we've seen here in
recent history with the quarterback as
explosive as any we've ever seen in the
history of football and a great and a
great buy week first game of the year
game plan designer and Andy Reid totally
scare me off the Jacksonville Jaguars I
would think they'd keep that game in
Houston this week with the Texans very
very close if not win the game I don't
know who's gonna win it yet I have to
figure that out yeah there's a chance
that team that beats you the first week
of the season is the best team in
football and we have seen teams lose
week one and get very hot the rest of
the way we've seen teams win week one
and fall apart the 2001 Carolina
Panthers won the first game of the
season proceeded to lose 15 in a row so
we can't read too much into week one and
the Jaguars still could end up winning
that division and who knows Gardner
Minshew could end up being the next Kurt
Warner or dak Prescott or Case Keenum in
2017 where you just think it's over in
comes the backup and the backup ends up
performing pretty well in winning one
game after another
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports